President Biden throwing a tone deaf
party for the ages on the same day the
stock market had its worst day since
June 2020 thanks to a worse than
expected inflation report Biden and
Democrats thought it would be
appropriate to hold a massive White
House Event to celebrate the passage of
his so-called inflation reduction act
which actually does nothing to solve the
problem Biden bringing 2 000 of his
closest friends to the South lawn
including a soothing performance by
James Taylor and how about James Taylor
a voice that heals our soul and unites
the nation and a good friend exactly
four weeks ago today I signed the
inflation reduction act in the law
a single most important legislation
passed in the Congress to combat
inflation the soul of America is vibrant
the future of America is bright and the
promise of America is real this bill cut
costs for families
help reduce inflation at the kitchen
table
but it didn't prices of food spiked to
their highest margins in more than four
decades and Biden's tone-deaf event
wouldn't be complete without the
inaccurate ramblings of good old Chuck
and Nancy
whoa
look at this crowd
so
this is a great and celebratory day
inflation reduction acts so beautifully
named for all that it does your
extraordinary leadership has made this
glorious day possible
I that's an Applause line
you know Greg inflation Rose higher than
expected in August keeping prices
painful uh for all Americans and yet it
was higher in fact than predicted and
yet they're over there celebrating what
are they celebrating about I don't know
it's like uh underwear at a flea market
I'm not buying it James Taylor again
why are we torturing people they did
this to the to the French after a
terrorist attack I mean come on at least
get somebody listenable I can make some
suggestions maybe The Melvins Slayer
Misfits something good I'm pleading with
Republicans you got to get your act
together you're never going to get an
opportunity like this this is like the
inmates are running the Asylum nothing
they say is true it's just like if you
can't if you can't beat these guys then
you don't deserve to win and it's sad I
go back to that rule you bet on the
person who wants it more and sometimes
it feels like the Democrats just want
this stuff more because they're just
more ruthless I mean they're calling
half of America terrorists that means he
came to play right they're making it so
that if you decide to challenge them on
anything you're considered unpatriotic
so I would I I and I would love to see
the Republicans kind of get as nasty as
they are uh and if you look at what the
Dems are doing which is elevating you
know the far right candidates again it
reminds you that politics that's the
Democrats line of work it's full time I
mean for Republicans it used to be you
know politics is something you do while
running your business but the Dems
politics is their business and that's
why they're better at it it's just like
I'm very sanguine is that the word I
learned that yesterday yes I don't I I
feel like you know that the Dems are now
stepping it up and the Republicans are
on their back foot you know Jesse
meanwhile it's this schizophrenic what
what Greg is talking about is this
schizophrenic approach where they're
putting all this money into the
right-wing candidates that are running
against a Democrat candidate and yet
they're trashing the right-wing
candidate what is the what is the agenda
here
well they're trying to win those Senate
races with that but permission to make
an analogy judges this would be like
your wife leaving you at the altar and
then just being like you know what let's
go dancing and cut some cake right this
would be like Hillary Clinton on the
night of the 2016 election firing off
the fireworks because they were already
paid for
real people see a number drop like this
and they cancel the party but
politicians can't do that because the
media covers everything they do because
the media would then say Biden cancels
inflation reduction act party after
inflation soars so instead they have to
pretend like everything is normal and
that's why this country is looking at
him like they're crazy because you're in
a recession the Dow just dropped a
thousand points but it doesn't matter if
you live in Fantasyland judge you know
doesn't matter you you can say that the
inflation reduction act reduces
inflation by spending a trillion dollars
you can say we're not in a recession you
can say whatever you want it gives me
these Vibes about Putin you remember did
you hear Yesterday they just lost a ton
of territory in Northeast Ukraine what
was Vlad doing he was at an unveiling of
a ferris wheel it's like nothing matters
if you just pretend like everything is
fine and until today I thought the
Republicans were going to lose the
Senate not anymore with this inflation
number that hits and these Senate
candidates that are falling apart and
all the money the Republicans are
injecting into these races I'm a little
more confident now except Lindsey Graham
comes out today and talks about abortion
you stole everybody else is talking
about inflation okay well before we talk
about that let's talk about the fact
Dana that you know we've got these
Democrat Senate candidates whether it's
fetterman who is refusing in
Pennsylvania to debate Oz or Mark Kelly
who fumbled the other day yesterday I
believe and he couldn't give any kind of
a comment on whether or not Joe Biden's
doing a good job and he says I don't
write report cards we have that sound
let's take a listen
has he done a good job do you think hey
you know I you know first of all it's
not my job to give him a report card I
would say you know mixed reviews so if
he came out here held an event you'd
attend that eventually I would certainly
consider it consider it's not Bob would
look at it
yeah he was fumbling right there and
that's his party so would we got this
how come the Republicans aren't jumping
all over this well I think that they are
so I'm going to give you some good news
so you don't have to be sanguine anymore
so uh last Tuesday when we came back
from Labor Day it did feel like the
Democrats had the wind behind their back
right and it was like wow they're doing
great but by Friday all these other
polls have come out and like oh actually
the Republicans are hanging in there
pretty well they are they have less
money than the Democrats and yet they
are still able to hold really steady
people don't really focus until after
Labor Day and then the the White House
you schedule events based on the
calendar you look and think oh okay well
the jobs number is coming out that day
they didn't know what the inflation
number was going to be but why do they
schedule the inflation reduction act on
the same day the inflation is coming out
that makes them look ridiculous and
everybody that's out there a great event
look lots of fun beautiful in September
a lot of those are staffers okay that's
not Americans that are dealing with this
or looking at their 401k and here you
have the White House this juxtaposition
is really strange they're popping
champagne for a bill that will take
working people's money and give it to
rich people so they can buy electric
vehicles and then there's the student
loan debt we know how that is going and
a lot of these races are are tightening
and people are forgetting remember what
happened in New Jersey there wasn't a
single poll in all of New Jersey
and that Republican came this close
right to winning and that hasn't changed
um think about young Ken think about
education crime is a big issue the
border is a big issue and this
you have the Democrats saying maybe our
polls are not as good as we think they
are because they're oversampling
Democrats so I'm not saying that the
Republicans are going to run away with
it but I do believe they are in better
shape than we thought a week ago I feel
less sanguine yeah
you know Jessica the truth is that the
Dem seemed as as Dana said they seem to
be in good shape they had a good summer
they had a legislative success but the
truth is that you know the the inflation
is five times higher
since when since Biden took office
prices of food is not going down even
though the price of gas is going down so
how do they play this going into
November well I think the Optics of
today were absolutely abominable and I
feel very bad for Senator Joe manchin
who's going to be on with Brett after
when we get out there and he wants to
talk about this act which he supported
and they had to work really hard to get
him on board with it and then he's going
to have to talk about you know the Dow
ticker versus the president talking
about this so I would have rescheduled
especially since it was majority
staffers and you know Thursday might
have been a better day for this uh the
race the races were always going to
tighten that's just what happens people
wake up they start paying attention and
I know Dana you saw the piece in the New
York Times as well Nate Cohen one of the
pollsters did an evaluation of the races
based on the uh the mistakes that were
made in 2020 so where Wisconsin was
supposed to be a win by like eight
points and it ended up being one point
and when he redid the tables the Dems
pick up one seat it was the fetterman
seat and all of this and that's still a
pickup I would be plenty happy if we
ended up with one extra seat I would be
overjoyed if we ended up with a couple
more and I think it is feasible
somewhere like Ohio for instance but
when you see some of these results that
Mandela Barnes is up nine points for
instance over Ron Johnson I don't
believe that I think it's going to be a
really close race
um I will say to Jesse's point about
Lindsey Graham just I guess waking up
and saying oh I I should go out by
myself and say we're going to have a
National Abortion ban when I actually
saw it previewed last night on Twitter I
thought oh no this is going to be
terrible because he'll be helping out
women in these states with these highly
restrictive bands but no it's even worse
than that the highly restrictive States
get to keep their policies and he's just
going after blue States or people with
more lenient policies and there's been
reporting after reporting about the
spike in women that are registering how
angry they are and that's Democrats
Independent Women and Republican women
and Mitch McConnell's face said it all
when he got asked about it and he was uh
yeah
but can I say Lindsey Graham didn't go
alone he did have Marjorie Den fensler
with who is the head of the Susan
he's introduced this very bill every
year for 20. but it used to be at 20
weeks and now he's gone to 15.
I understand but I don't want to hear
from a man about abortion I certainly
don't want to hear from a man who hasn't
had kids about abortion he should never
have done this so did we men have no
opinion on abortion okay you have no
opinion on can we pick something
vasectomies there you go yeah how about
war you do you have no opinion on war
because we sent boys off to war for
Generations
but I know what I mean but I know more
than you know get the last word all
right
I want to Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now